no the nominated songs now you open it
honey I don't do site fit
right now this is a very great honor
thank you very much and I want to thank
you from the bottom of my somewhat
damaged heart at this juncture may I
introduce a young man who was breaking
in his white tie his tales and his
material at the same time mr. Mort saw
well we just lost the college crowd and
they're all over America they're saying
sellout but it's ok sir Lawrence will be
out later in the sweater for those of
you are waiting now I want to mention
first of all I think recognition is do
Transworld airlines or TWA as it's known
at the corner for flying the foreign
personnel in and miss Marcee out
although she was referred to earlier and
sterling Hayden took the boat I checked
all this before we started the I we're
gonna have a category later for the the
best Diane Bar C joke we're coming for
that later
I did I didn't want to mention among
other things that I'm just barely in the
Academy and I just did one picture
although I was going to say about TWA
one point the jet started April 1st I
understand I just found that out
backstage and as you know when flight
when they fly over Kansas it's a dry
state and his stewardesses also
announced that it'll be a 30-second
break when the bar will be closed I want
to mention that earlier anyway that's
some of the problem now just to know
that we're organized I was gonna the
first picture I worked on at all Actors
Studio people in it now you may have
some out front and are usually New York
actors and a lot of them have been out
here between five and seven years on
studios secure contracts but they don't
want to give in to the town so they
usually live in hotels and for five or
seven years and in rent cars and they
don't maintain long relationships and
most of them shop at night we have two
all night markets here in Hollywood and
they walk in there at night and they
usually shop in very Spartan fashion and
buy something like maybe instant coffee
and we'll light know for the Sox and
coke this is for real and then the
checker always says I don't you want to
buy more than one coke about the
six-pack any actors always say well no
because I might be going back to New
York
so so whenever you talk to them they
always say things like they don't say
that
they think this is a phony town you know
because they do have integrity they're
hard to talk to because these are bright
guys all been in analysis as I say don't
say they say say well I yeah I think
it's a phony town but I'm kind of tired
of the theater in New York because New
York is a sterile town but I did stock
in the Midwest I know that's a cultural
desert and I had to leave my home in the
south because I was suffocating as a
person so there's not an awful lot you
say to that you know like yeah were you
happy on the train
for authority anyway we I was going to
give the two awards tonight to the
longest location trip and I didn't get a
chance to which would it was uncontested
it was supposed to go through Stanley
Kramer for making on the beach in
Australia before the world beats him to
it I might add and also because the
picture is you know has to do with the
recession that we suffered but we're
over now luckily and as you know earlier
this the picture is about a hydrogen war
that's what it's about camera the book
and at the end of this war which goes on
for 12 years of stalemate between Russia
in the United States then at the end of
that time there only eight people left
alive on earth and four of them are out
of work that's all I was gonna say now I
said one bulletin I found out that
President Truman was in the audience
and he got four seats it's kind of lucky
that way and I mentioned some of the
younger actresses only know backstage
you know only know mr. Eisenhower and I
explained President Truman in terms of
how I know him best I was in a service
under General MacArthur that's the frame
of reference
really
as you recall a General MacArthur led us
through the water you'll recall I
returned with the right I will return
with the scrambled eggs in the cap and
his ribbons right remember and they
opened shirt and then he walked through
the water there and there was a rumor in
our outfit that he had originally
planned to walk on the water but
President Truman had interfere
the next category is fixed it's for the
most active network in bringing you the
Academy Awards and the nominations as I
understood them where CBS and it starts
with Cuban and goes on from there the
initials and the next word for ABC and
then the mutual network I think they've
got a radio man out in the press tent
and NBC and I brought the envelope here
which have opened a safe time and the
winner is NBC
the National Broadcasting Company and I
hope right now the stockholders will
come forward and identify themselves
station by station